Hugo what was your big takeaway from
their spokesperson I think the big
takeaway was I felt like I was really in
a parallel universe at V FIFA
headquarters and said among the
manicured perfect football pitches we
were sitting in the house of football
listening to the chief spokesman talk
about the fact that set bladder is quote
not involved in this scandal and that he
definitely was sure that the world cups
in Qatar and Russia would go ahead and
so to hear him talking in such absolute
terms I think left a lot of people
scratching their heads and saying how
can that bladder not be involved he
heads up the whole organization and he
has since 1998 Ken Lay didn't know there
was problems at Enron it's basically the
same situation who knows whether
stepladder did or didn't know what is
absolutely certain is that everybody is
wondering I'm wondering Stephanie's
wondering I'm sure Hugo you wanting the
same thing who's going to cop a plea how
long is it going to take for somebody to
turn state's evidence with us
prosecutors and take down the whole
freaking organization 14 people how
could the guy on top not be involved and
let's just say he isn't involved then
what the heck is he doing all day long
what that's another excellent point Hugo
if stepladder didn't know that any of
this was happening given all the
investigations that have taken place
what business does he have being elected
to another term as president of FIFA
Eric it you you you took the words right
out of one or two questions that came
during the press conference people ask
this Ino can set bladder be accountable
if he does not know about this and and
is quote unquote not involved and I
think that that a lot of people are
asking that question and also asking if
the Swiss and the American prosecutors
are going after FIFA for this how can
they not have brought set bladder
himself in for questioning I mean if he
runs the whole show and he has for 25
years surely he has to answer some
questions directly I mean no man can I
above the law hold on one more time they
didn't even question him he has had no
conversations you not not at this point
now of course there's a lot that goes on
that FIFA does not
the press or or the world about but at
this point we we don't have any evidence
that you know someone said okay mr.
bladder you need to come down sit down
and talk with us and as we know he
certainly was not among the among the
seven arrested this morning and rather
unceremoniously at 6am in the hotel
right behind me should we have seen him
speaking today well of course I mean if
you're accountable step ladders should
have been up there instead of walter de
Gregorio the flak for FIFA and as to
whether or not as the body and will
spokesperson spokesperson but as the
weather or why Sepp Blatter does Lee
doesn't get questioned by the DOJ we're
going to learn what kind of tactics and
strategy prosecutors employ when we talk
to chris garcia former prosecutor with a
Southern District of New York later on
this morning if there was ever a moment
to say the buck stops here he should
have been standing there in front of the
all of nothing to fear why wouldn't you
stand there that's what everybody's life
has not been put in this position ever
and he put a spokesperson out a
spokesperson out there that surprises me
well well you're all familiar with the
game where's waldo i think a lot of us
here have been feeling like we've been
playing where sep I was at the African
Confederation meeting this morning where
he was like perhaps expected to show no
sign of sep I went straight from there
to the press conference in zurich
headquarters he wasn't even there and
from what I understand he didn't show up
at a meeting of the South American
Federation so he certainly has not put
himself forward I think he feels it he
doesn't have to because in a way I think
he feels I wasn't named among the seven
I'm vindicated or at least that's the
line of argument that his spokesman I'm
right here shutting out right now FIFA
is an international Oh like I said
parallel universe Viva is an
international joke this guy has been
running the organization for over 20
years and it's not his problem please if
he knew about it he should be booted if
he didn't know about it he should be
booted quicker